hey it's Justine and today I'm gonna
show you guys this new app that just
came out it's called double take it's by
filmic Pro you guys may remember at the
iPhone 11 keynote a filmic pro was out
on stage talking about how they were
gonna be integrating this feature into
filmic Pro now you can shoot with
multiple cameras at the same time
instead of integrating it into their
already paid app they came out with an
entirely brand-new app and that's called
double tape so I'm going to show you
guys the app I have it running right now
we're gonna go through some of these
settings and I'll show you guys exactly
how this works so when you click down
here on this little lens button this
will take you into all four camera
options you guys can see you have the
ultra wide the wide the telephoto and of
course the selfie so for this I'm going
to choose the egg-cam as my selfie and
the B cam is the ultra wide so you can
also change your frame rate by clicking
on the frame rates
you've thirty 24 and 25 we're gonna
shoot in 24 because that's what I shoot
most my YouTube videos at
let's click confirm' and that will take
us into this little setting right here
so this is where the fun really starts
because you've got a couple of options
here so up here in the top right and so
when you click that you can go through
all the things you can record at the
same time you know split-screen you also
have discrete which I love this a lot
because it records both camera streams
and you can separately export those so
they won't be burned in like this
picture and picture option so with
picture in picture that is basically
what you're gonna get you can be editing
on the fly so we're gonna start with the
picture and picture so when you hit
record this records your entire screen
so right now you guys will be seeing me
move around this ultra wide screen right
here and that's happening live on this
app you can also get rid of it it's gone
click right here this little arrow it'll
be back if you want to enlarge that
second camera you can and you gonna go
back to it there I am and you're doing
this all live on the fly so you just
scoot that right over to the side it's
gone I'm on screen you want that to come
back click this little button its back
you want to just fullscreen this you can
this is live switching and editing on
the fly it's pretty cool next is
split-screen I love this I actually
tested this out with my sister we were
at a super 73 launch event I was in the
front facing and she was in the back so
we were basically having a conversation
in split-screen just like yeah I'm gonna
change the camera angle really quickly
here so this D camera I'm gonna do a
telephoto now this I'm gonna be zoomed
in on my little monitor so here we have
this split screen I'm over here on the
selfie cam and in the telephoto is my
Atomos ninja five second camera where
are you you're right there we're not
using you right now like you're there
you can also flip it and you can shoot
vertical here's a vertical option I'm in
the selfie cam the ninja is also in it
this is cool this is gonna be so great
for Instagram stories so now we're
recording discreetly this is using both
camera angles and these are shooting
separately I can use the selfie cam or I
can flip to the front so here's my hand
it's going to the front hand front hand
front so if you guys can tell so these
are recorded separately things like
concerts or events you could be filming
your reaction but also filming the
action in front of you so now that
you've shot all this incredible content
where does it go so in here there's a
little looks like an SD card this will
bring up all of these shots that you've
recorded so if you want to select them
all you just click that little checkbox
and these will all be saved directly to
your camera roll so when we go to the
camera roll here's the picture and
picture that we shot here's the split
screen here's the split screen vertical
and of course here's the discrete
there's the other camera angle of
discrete so this app is really fun I'm
excited to try this out a little bit
further to be able to do that just on
this phone is pretty awesome
it does only record 1080p I thought that
it might record 4k but still the fact
that you'll be able to record both of
those streams most the time the 1080p
and the 4k versions of these videos
usually things on YouTube
can't tell a difference usually I do
like to have everything shot in 4k but
this is gonna be really cool and I'm
excited to see the fun things that I can
do with this especially for Instagram
stories or tic toc or now even the new
bike app you guys are on bite make sure
you guys follow me hopefully by this
time I've got my username back but if I
did it my username is I just seem real
so that's really me I'd love to hear
what you guys think of this app and I'd
love to see some of the things that you
guys shoot with it feel free to tweet me
any of your video creations that you
guys make with it hopefully I'll see
some of you guys a vlog University this
weekend it's gonna be so much fun it'll
be here before we know it
I'm gonna go and prep for the event this
weekend okay
[Music]